[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
let me ask you something when you say
asian people look alike do you believe
in that stereotype no no i don't but
that's only because our friends our best
friends are asian but i will tell you
this our best friends raisin and their
daughter um their daughter tried out for
the softball team in her school and she
comes home
she goes i'm concerned it's i'm not
gonna make the team when we go we're all
out of their house we go why she goes
because there's another girl there's
another asian girl that actually really
looks like me mom and she sucks and i'm
afraid they're going to confuse us
so we're like okay
and then they go and she goes actually
the girl's not that bad so they're
equally talented and they're the same
height and they look identical oh wow
and so
the girl our friend's daughter made the
team and then she
we go you made the team she goes yeah
but i had to go up to the coach and go
did you get the right asian
i don't think i i
i used to have a joke about that and
that i go um i do you ever see the same
person twice in one day
and you're like oh my god
i saw this asian lady 15 times in one
day she was everywhere she was at
cleaners she was at the nail salon she
cut me off in traffic three times yeah
and so i got into therapy right after
the j and me [ __ ] went down
my biggest mistake i ever did was
telling joey diaz i was in therapy and
he was like dawg [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
guy's got a [ __ ]
yeah you meet me every morning for 8 am
a coffee and me and joey had 8 a.m
coffee for a month
one month every day and he go talk say
everything you need to [ __ ] say and i
would dump on him dump on him and then
joey would come back and be like here's
the problem [ __ ] you know yeah
tell them what i do at a restaurant if i
pay so if he pays um i'm taking out some
people
let's say you ordered a 65 steak tastes
delicious um you only eat half you want
to take some home to your kids and i'm
paying for it if he's paying for it
you're not allowed to take anything i
like that
i like exactly why i like that a lot
that's mine i like oh
wrapped up and then bobby just goes yeah
one box no i leave i don't even take it
in fact i've done this before i leave it
on the table
no one can take it i've taken the box
i've secretly packed it in a box and
he's done this to a sandwich of mine
looked at it
smashed my sandwich so it's now all over
the place and then out of
it's hilarious and the next time you pay
for the meal you can take it home do
whatever you want with it that is so
brilliant wait what's the most exercise
you ever do the stairs up here oh yeah
you're mine at all oh he doesn't even
know they exist up there in beechwood
when i do let me say something right now
you're the best hike right up your head
all right all right chris okay
let me just say something we went
[ __ ] hiking a couple of weeks ago
when he um his sugar dropped he became
hypoglycemic and i had to drive the car
up the hill on the hike trail to pick
him up oh you're smiling that's right no
i think that's i think that's totally
natural
you think it is i text steve back and he
i go he's looking for you
and steve goes i'm looking for him what
does he look like and i write back he's
korean
and he goes i know but what's he look
like and i go like you but more
hip-hoppy
and he's like no but describe him i go
olive skin black hair
slightly uh
what the [ __ ] steve he's [ __ ] korean
how do you describe yeah i go just look
for yourself but like cooler yeah
and then all of a sudden he goes oh
never mind i found him hip hop is a good
question
triathlon i've done a sprint triathlon i
want to do one of those yeah those are
fun yeah i'm gonna say something about
with bobby bobby ride the bike
i'll do the run bobby
who has one let's do a malibu relay okay
ride the bike hold on one second i can
guarantee you that i can come out of
that pack i love this kind of talk right
here i can guarantee you i
listen to me i can get you top 25 out
the water okay all right you lose that
lead i swear to god i'm out the team
okay no i i i guarantee you i will train
yeah and i will get us
top
top
i'm not top 25 out of the water i'm not
i can't go that high but i get us i'll
keep us into the top just keep what's in
the pocket i'll keep up our cyclist
that's the final leg no cyclist is the
second leg i'm not doing it okay you're
the run so you have to bobby bobby let's
do this this is what dude this is what
this is what dreams are made of
listen man
let's do something right now all you got
to do is ride a bike [ __ ] up man all
right
you first of all you can't make
decisions without me you guys are making
all these plans and stuff i got to get
in on it all right i even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about get in all
right i'm going to get on and on all
right
i just want to say this okay no no no no
no no no i just want to say this all
right what's going on we're doing a
triathlon okay let's start from the
beginning okay start from the beginning
what's going on sprint tag team malibu
okay so it's
going to be in six months
it's a real thing it's a real thing okay
so you do how many people are involved
three we need to try we're a three-man
team yeah okay
so what do i do
all you gotta do is wait for me to tag
you and then you bike you ride a bike
how far it's not that far how far
right around the world
km
is that 40 feet
40 feet is not 40 feet like i think it's
like what's 40k okay it's a nautica
malibu triathlon
and let me see i got the run part
how long do i have to ride a bike give
me two months to train get the three of
us and let's put up money on a betting
site
and let people try to beat us all right
yes george just said it's 25 miles
that's not bad
just listen listen that's riding from
the area
okay let me just say this
you'll never find me again
bobby
you will find
60 years from now in some forest
the remains of a bike right
and a skeleton a fat skeleton
just craving it like a [ __ ] baby
as well don't ever want to go to your
house no you guys i want to i i want to
do a house we're not going to we're not
going to be there no no no no no no no
no no
i thought you guys should meet each
other you guys are all my amazing
friends number three you got you and i
are kindred spirits we we are hardcore
we're very similar in many ways and um
and this is you know you and i could
talk forever i could talk to you i could
do it
i wish my podcast was just fun
no it's fun with you it's not always
this fun
it's fun when you're here who's been a
bad guest
you know i need people to add
information so i've had people on where
i asked them something and they say
maybe two or three words and they're
waiting and then you have to rev up
again and you know and i don't like that
i'm turning the cameras off oh wait
there's one more thing i wanted to tell
you what [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go that's
like
you had been saving this
so you had someone on your podcast that
is my ultimate life idol um kimmy swimmy
yes so i free dive and she is somebody
that i like my entire life is modeled
around trying to be kimmy werner let's
go let's go to let's go to hawaii she
just had a baby let's go to hawaii with
her i would love to okay i love her so
much hold on hold on hold on this will
totally happen never going to happen
let's go to let's go i have kimmy's
number i know kimmy really well yeah
we'll go down we'll go down and she'll
teach me i've never i've done it a
couple times i've gone spearfishing
that's another thing i want to tell you
we should go free dive can you should
get your lobster license and you should
come with me and i'll take you out to go
um get some lobsters uh a hundred
percent 100
well lobster season's almost over but
is the people talking bobby how did how
do you how are you as someone so active
and and you're like nothing nothing
zero's gonna happen
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna have
bernalina i'm gonna tell bernalillo
we're gonna shoot it for all things
comments absolutely and we'll go down
we'll go spear fishing free diving with
kimmy she was like within a day i can
get you to hold your breath for like two
minutes and i was like oh wow i'm gonna
lose
next a minute 30 right now
wow that's really good actually you know
what he actually holds his breath very
very long his lung capacity is better
than mine me love you a long time
[Laughter]
i mean me oh hero
i hope you're cool talking about this
but when the carlos mencia video came
out oh my god and then the next day you
gave the talk holding a cigarette oh my
god
i was like i'm that guy
could i just say this i've been i've
never identified with anyone more i
can't believe you just said that
the thing you did the way you talked
about it the way you expressed regret
and
it was such in the vein that i lived my
life where i went i went oh my god dude
i i can i tell you i've pictured where
you were in life meaning like location i
was like oh he's in los feliz he's on
he's out by his back step
right by that door like i visualized
that oh my god i'm so glad you brought
that up yeah
because that video plagued me
for real yeah because this is how that
happened so i joe puts out
that montage video of mencia stealing
and whatnot and i was in the video i
visualized i visualized how it happened
to you can i can i tell you what i
thought happened yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna tell you yeah okay i
thought you walked up to the store
what's going on yeah someone's like uh
bob you got a cigarette you're like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna smell one
too and you little cigarette and
someone's like and then then everyone
starts walking out and you're sitting
there by the wall and they're like bobby
what do you think about uh carlos
masteal and you and you're just jokingly
went you mean ned not knowing what it
happened yeah yeah yeah and then and
then just walked away and then all of a
sudden the video comes out and carlos
called you and was like bro what the
[ __ ] oh yeah he feels very simple very
similar to that i envisioned that so
much because i was like
you were a little bit of the nail in the
coffin
in the in the storytelling you and
i
were a little bit of like the
the this is oh my god so wait tell me
how it really this is hap what happened
okay
so i'm at the comedy store and
brian redband at the time
wasn't reddit brian redband of today
byron redband was
joe rogan's guy
his video autographer
his podcast guy everything and brian red
brandon would always have a camera just
on
right and so i'm walking
at night like i always do and somebody
asked me what about mencia stealing i
don't see the camera was this the same
night that this whole thing went down or
no they it was it was it was a collage
of a bunch of different things so it was
a different night right
so he got and i said
i didn't know there was a camera there
and and they said but mancine is
stealing yeah he steals or whatever you
know
then i noticed the thing and then i go
to brian i go
don't put that out there
and brian goes no i mean job makes the
final decision but we're probably not
the extent
it is right
so here's the [ __ ] part by the way you
got to give a shout out to brian redman
for shooting content
a week earlier then shooting this and
then realizing i got bobby lee saying
that he steals that's a good producer's
mind like
that's a really great like crafty yeah
that's brian redman's a gangster we have
a big party one night and uh and for
some whatever reason no one drank beer
and so we had a a
a whole igloo freezer cooler full of
beer
and
it where it was placed it was it had a
towel over it no one saw it and so it
sat there forever so then all of a
sudden one day i go oh [ __ ] this i open
it and all the water smells like [ __ ]
and all the beers labels are faded and
so i take out all the beers and then i
go i'm going to throw them away i know
it's drinking these [ __ ] beers i put
them in the alley
put them in the alley
and
i no sooner leave my house to go to
starbucks and i start walking by the
alley and i see a homeless guy grabbing
my beers and my immediate instinct was
hey don't take my [ __ ] beers i didn't
want them i didn't want
and i put him in the them for someone to
take and as he was taking him i was like
my instinct was don't take my beers
i didn't want to see it yeah that makes
sense yes like i didn't want to see them
i would be
i we our neighbor has lemon tree and i
always i always say to him hey george
you mind if i grab a lemon by the way
i've literally described my where i live
to a tea if you're looking for a lemon
tree a starbucks in an alley you're like
and a half full fig tree and a half full
fig tree you're like i think i know
where burt lives in other countries they
don't care that much about their cars
like
just listen to what i'm saying
let's go ahead let's go i was in
thailand i saw two cab drivers hit each
other they put their head out the window
and they looked at their cars okay it's
fine let's move on and they kept driving
my point is is that it's not that big of
a if you get like a little scratch here
in america yeah you pull over you know i
mean you call people all that stuff it's
like in asia we don't give that much a
[ __ ] about yeah you're right are you
dead is the car still work let's move on
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]